we want to take a closer look at galaine
maxwell who just went on trial yesterday
for alleged sex trafficking in opening
statements prosecutors describe maxwell
as jeffrey epstein's lady of the house
they're calling her who set up teenage
girls for him to sexually abuse
the defense denies those allegations and
argues that she's on trial for crimes
that epstein committed this display in a
new york city courtroom is very
different from the way that she lived
most of her life as holly williams
reports from london
good morning galen maxwell grew up here
in the united kingdom in immense wealth
and privilege we wanted to find out how
she went from this to a new york jail on
trial on sex trafficking charges as we
discovered it's a complicated story
the ocean has just ended up being
basically the largest
dust bin in the world this is galen
maxwell in 2014. i'm here representing
civil society six years after jeffrey
epstein's first conviction she was
running an environmental organization
and still enjoying the high life
socializing with the uber wealthy and
the famous here in britain though glenn
maxwell grew up a nouveau riche outsider
much of britain's elitist establishment
is not amused by mr maxwell her father
robert maxwell was profiled by 60
minutes in 1988. a jewish refugee from
czechoslovakia turned brash newspaper
tycoon just give him the message please
and stop giving us a half time
[Music]
gulen was reportedly his favorite child
he even named his yacht after her but he
had a reputation as a bullying tyrant
including to his children i remember
being in a room full of people when
maxwell walked in and everybody stopped
talking
and you know outside clint eastwood
movies that really doesn't happen very
often john preston wrote a biography of
robert maxwell were people frightened
yes i think
people treated him with a strange
mixture of kind of awe and ridicule the
body had been brought out of the ces
when the magnate drowned mysteriously in
1991 it was discovered that maxwell had
embezzled hundreds of millions of
dollars leaving glenn maxwell and her
siblings humiliated and reportedly
strapped for cash they were the children
of someone who'd been branded public
enemy number one
serial killers have had better press
than robert maxwell she was this
mysterious uh
glamorous
woman she but by 1997 when journalist
vicky ward first met galen maxwell at a
party she'd transformed herself into a
darling of new york society she was
always name-dropping henry kissinger
bill clinton the question was how there
were designer clothes there were clearly
lots of private planes and i did think
gosh
who's
paying for all this ward later wrote a
profile of jeffrey epstein for vanity
fair discovering that maxwell was his
ex-girlfriend and uncovering early
allegations of sexual abuse against the
pair which ward's editors wouldn't allow
her to publish they say she needed more
sources
he
controlled
the money
that she needed
access to she introduced him to rich
people to important people to people
like prince andrew she'd befriended the
so-called party prince in the 1980s he
denies that maxwell and epstein
trafficked a 17 year old to him for sex
i i have no recollection of ever meeting
her
but ward told us other former friends of
glenn maxwell now refuse to speak on the
record fearful their reputations will be
tarnished is there a possibility that
galen maxwell
was jeffrey epstein's victim in some
sense
that according to my reporting is what
her defense
will argue
in court
for cbs morning's holly williams london
that is so fascinating because most
people know nothing about this woman and
the fact that she's now sitting in a
jail cell i'm sure she's wondering how
the hell did this happen but when you
look at what the victims are saying
right and the role she played it it's
it's really really really disturbing
yeah i mean the key question was always
like how could she get mixed up in this
and the storyline laid out by the vanity
fair reporter suggested that there was a
financial falling out in her family and
then jeffrey epstein might have been the
solution to that problem from a life of
opulence to now being looked at as a
villain yeah for sure